all right these gentlemen are making
their way to Ann Arbor headlining the
Ann Arbor Comedy Showcase in Michigan
Thursday through Saturday September 20th
through 22nd go to a a comedy calm for
tickets check them out also on the
history of comedy series on CNN the
roast battle on Comedy Central and their
view from the cheap seats podcast the
Sklar brothers Randy and Jason you know
I want to start with this one I you
could have not no word the feather seen
you guys in better call Saul last season
that was so fun I mean yeah because
audition not for brothers just two guys
who owned a music store and we came in
and we saw like all of our friends who
are really great actors comedians and
people and we loved the show like I
loved I almost didn't want to book the
part because I didn't want to screw up
on my favorite show like it was it was
it takes you out of it just seeing
yourself in that whole thing but run
shots so cool I mean the way they shoot
that show they're just like rehearse and
Odenkirk is someone that we've known
from the comedy scenes 90s what him and
David Cross mr. show and just that whole
sort of Largo Los Angeles group of like
alternative comedians and whatnot we
knew him and he was really happy that we
were there and just great to hang out
with him we'd just be rehearsing with
him in the spot where we were and all of
a sudden the cameras like up in the
ceiling kind of shooting from down here
and it just felt like we're talking
right here like there were no cameras
around us they said go run it a couple
times and in those couple of times they
shot it it was amazing so it was like
the most natural way to reshoot
something it's great how about that it's
an amazing set and I was it's in
Albuquerque you shoot in Albuquerque and
I got there and I immediately was like
hakeem olajuwon
in the NCAA championship game I was like
on the sidelines getting oxygen it's
fifty two hundred oh yeah that's what
you did oh man I was trying to trying to
see what you're going team Olajuwon did
during yeah appreciate you going sports
and I kind of laid an egg a little bit
Hopper blue velvet is more of
sort of inhaling oxygens an Albuquerque
thing and that had nothing yeah yes it
was like and also explaining to people
how they should not look at him yeah
that was in your life did you ever see
blue velvet Chris oh that's going to
completely over your head no idea okay I
thought the blue you're going meth the
world's happen to your Cardinals guys
they are on fire right now huh went to
the game the other night and I was there
and you know we were down one nothing
flirty is pitching great he's actually
throwing a no-hitter then Jacques
Peterson hits one out not you Jew
congratulations yeah I know we we had
Jeff Schwartz here in the studio nice
and we had him sign the the book of
great Jews that's amazing we should sign
it too although a sports show back in
the day did we achieve seats
oh no this Terrell Owens Jewish yes but
as a matter of fact that's why I didn't
go to the hall he's complaining about
the portions it was on Shabbat too he
could not do it that was that's one you
want to go to yeah you can line up as
many guys behind you in century 21
jackets and make it look like they're
also going in the Hall of Fame Oh like
you know how like at the at the Hall of
Fame induction ceremony they show
pictures of you during your playing days
have a picture of the x-ray of the
broken leg he played on during the Super
Bowl yes there remind everyone how great
you are in front of everybody you know
I'm thought we might talk about Terrell
Owens today I just did not think that
the through line would be the addition
is Jewish and you watched him at home
running the home run and I thought to
myself in years past
Karnas would have folded earlier this
year earlier this year they would have
folded but they came back and hit that
dinger off of a kenley jansen I was
amazed and then what's a guy in whose
daughter was born that day yeah throw
that guy in the game
you're the Cardinals are like and I say
this with like a Yankee fan where I
understand that that that the Yankees
are viewed as the old US Steel yeah
Cardinals are like the Packers you know
where they are always first they're like
the Spurs always they're always in it
they always have somebody that you put
on another team might not be although
biscottis kind of he's now on and so
that's all you want as a fan base is to
have your team be in it at this time of
year now we may not make the playoffs
we're leading the the wild-card right
now but as the fans in st. Louis I was
just back in st. Louis they're excited
because you've got something to be
interested in that's why I actually love
the wild-card in in baseball right now
cuz there are so many teams that are
still in Milwaukee fans are still
excited about a Colorado fans are still
excited so how'd your friends your fans
slowly like why did we pay all this
money for Machado
so that's right you know Philly fan well
I mean everybody it's everybod Philly
fans you can be excited about this but
you won the Superbowl you won the
Superbowl so you can't complain about
any of your a Philly sports fan no you
won the Superbowl you can't complain
about it no score brothers here on the
Rich Eisen show no no no the sports to
me is like the Gordon Gekko greed is
good is good once you get one you want
more in Philly fans so if Philly fans
focus and grab me a water ice Laurel
we're from cherry cherry held on out
there he swallowed so many John John ham
on Jerry Lewis is medicine that's where
Doug Peterson looks like a fat guy in
fat John I want you to look at Doug
Peterson on the sidelines the next time
and just be like jon Hamm's character
work is amazing right he's unbelievable
and it is while we had Doug Peterson the
week we had the fat Jon Hamm on earlier
there's this book fearless I'm gonna
tweet out a side-by-side that
do a side-by-side sabes so it looks like
if you zipped up sort of like a a men in
black skin suit right right over John
Hamm it's I don't know episode of like
Mad Men in the late 80s a little too
much he did really well for him so I
mean he was jerking hard on the book
last night because you know the Eagles
weren't doing anything
five-nothing why is it okay well hold I
say I want to take a break because I
know where you're gonna go with this
when you say you've got a great Baker
Mayfield take yes I would like to it's a
taker Mayfield let's see what they can
take gourmet feel I like hearing that
and I do want to hit with you because
you know your your aunt Arbor people
your Michigan people that's getting the
same thing as me is that if you say
anything about what's going on at Ohio
State you're just a bit Homer you're a
bitter burnt as you can tell you how to
combat that okay on the back in 60
seconds with the Sklar brothers here in
the recharge part welcome back to their
rich Eisen show view from the cheap
seats podcast check it out I'm gonna be
on next week correct will be I guess it
drops next Friday you had Richard
Simmons on recently Richard sent we had
him on a while ago and then we replayed
it just because that's the guy I mean
that's not to say he's disappeared under
the country's under the control of his
made apparent that's what that's what
I'm okay
Schwarzenegger by the way so short and
you're back in Ann Arbor headlining the
Ann Arbor Comedy Showcase
yep Thursday through Saturday September
23 22nd that's the weekend they play who
Nebraska Nebraska
okay that's a big one that's gonna
surprise people this year hey Scott
frost is a terrific coach we've seen
what he did it at UCF he's coming home
they I think Nebraska fans are viewing
him in the same way that Michigan fans
are viewing Jim Harbaugh years ago like
the only guy that could come in and all
knows the program that everyone can
rally around is a fan base and believe
that there's some good times ahead
we've done some stuff in Omaha and and
been around Nebraska fans and they're a
proud you know the you got to live up to
the the behemoth that it was Tom Osborne
but they love their football program and
they want to bring it back to prominence
now Wisconsin kind of has a stranglehold
on the West there's no way anybody's
gonna unseat them now but in a couple of
years it could be different yeah yeah I
mean the same way that Scott frost was
the quarterback for Osborn I mean
Harbaugh was the quarterback for Bo
exactly and so I mean there's a lot of a
through line right there nearly similar
story and this is the year for Harbaugh
to really make the mark I feel like
everybody Michigan inside and outside of
Michigan it's like this is it you got to
do it this year and then your st. Louis
Nebraska connection is his Kurt when her
son Cade is a walk-on there is he really
he scored in the spring game did he
really say why groceries like his dad
did and then BOOM he'll make it yeah I
think that's I think that's you know an
interesting suggestion for him to try
next time you see Kurt Warner your son
should bag groceries like you did I'm
sure he would appreciate that paper or
plastic
give me your own that's what people say
now right give me what you bring your
own NPR tote bag so are you hearing
people saying that you're not a lot of
criticizing estate because yes we're
hearing that you're not allowed to
criticize the process you're not allowed
to criticize Ohio State you're hearing
Urban Meyer didn't do anything wrong
personally so we lied to the media who
cares we're hearing most of that from
Ezekiel Elliot's dad yeah that's weird
yeah it's just texting us we don't need
that but as Michigan fans I think people
the big thing that people say is you as
Michigan fans want to see urban get
taken down you're sad that he that he
wasn't fired and Michigan fans to a
person that we've talked to don't feel
that way no because they feel like if he
goes out then we're gonna get and if we
win this year by some chance like we
beat Luke fickle the last time it's
gonna be they don't want to get fickle
din to a victory don't to get fickle
right fickle victory is a hollow win
it's just slightly like look they've got
all the towel in the world
Ohio State and Urban's gonna come back
after three games that don't matter at
all why wouldn't you hold one game
really cuz he's coaching all week during
the other way the only worse the only
worse thing than getting fickle would be
getting Schiano to think you don't want
to get chiana date right that's that
that's who they would be that's who they
went with they would you would get dead
you would get to it but Willis agree
with you I agree with you I mean you
want to beat the best is he
is it weird that like kids sold the
shoes that they got at North Carolina
they got four games yeah oh gosh what
does Jim Tressel saying right now Jim is
Russell's like I let some kids sell some
pants and I lost my job how about how
about Gurley how many games did Gurley
get set for for AJ Green today AJ Green
so I mean I just think I just think
you're sending a terrible message so now
Urban Meyer you're gonna come back you
can never say to your players
that's that I'm gonna teach you how to
be men I'm gonna I'm gonna mold you from
it would've been better if Ohio State
just came out and said look we did these
findings we found all this stuff we like
here's the yeah we love winning we love
winning that's just it we're good at it
he's a great coach great coach he's the
next best coach next to Nick Saban we
want to win
therefore we place winning above
everything else at this university this
is a fact deal with it if you don't like
it you won't like it how many games the
DES get for having dinner with Deon like
ten I think what unbelievable it's the
first couple they had a ruling and then
he was out the rest of the year
unbeliev I mean it's talking about here
it's like again it's like maybe you
didn't know some stuff but you knew what
he did in 2009 you knew what the guy did
in 2015 there were other reports if you
are a coach who doesn't know what your
assistant coaches are doing on a regular
basis the only thing I believe a job as
a coach the only thing I believe is that
he was taking medication that that
messed with his man I mean that for
comedians like you ask Larr brothers
that is like a gift or a magic pill
literally yeah yeah maybe forget about
all the stuff that I I mean to me that
is like a coach's version of shaggy's it
wasn't me what's your Excuse
it wasn't me it wasn't me I took
medication I just don't even remember
being me it's it's the like life version
of my Twitter feed got hacked no it
didn't it didn't my one time it actually
did get hacked
idiot buddy of mine at my poker tables
II grabbed my text that grabbed my phone
so much yeah that's a radio was hacked
what are you looking at me like that for
you just really like that's not okay sir
may feel take yes the Sklar brothers
here at Sklar brothers on twitter what
your Baker Mayfield tech yeah I think
he's well now you never know how serious
this pinky injury is for Tara Taylor who
knows I mean and if he's making
decisions like he did in that game
yesterday he might get out but we might
see Baker Mayfield sooner Baker Mayfield
is like the tight heat to me is the guy
who shows up at a party with a six-pack
of Zima he walks in and you're like well
this is a bad idea what is well how why
are we doing this and then you start to
drink it a little bit and you're like
it's better than I thought it would
cause right now I did not invent unil
there's nothing about this that said we
should have done this and you drink it
and you say you know what I'm feeling
good parties really fun parties really
glad he came I'm happy it's better than
the party was last year the clear beer
of quarterback the clear beer I love
actually have loved what I've seen of
him so far did you hear what Jay Glazer
said on the pregame show no what he said
he said while he was taking Mike del to
four you had to have heard it because
you miked him up for that last night
might come up I was mixing itself I
heard it clearer because of you mixed
improperly he said that the way that he
has been playing the way that he
sometimes throws coming off the edge the
way that he performs yeah is a way that
he's not seen somebody drafted first
overall performed in 26 years of doing
so I think that's great is what he said
but both of us also think the Browns
screwed up and should have taken sake
one Berkeley first and they said God
made you still a god Mayfield it for
there is no way Mayfield sticks around
because the Jets would have gotten darn
old I just see you see him and I don't
know I think if Berkeley was gone
if Berkeley was gone the Giants would
have traded out and somebody would have
come in for a quarterback or the Giants
would have taken the quarterback and it
would have been darn 'old mm-hm and then
the Jets would have hopped on Mayfield
you think so I don't believe so
it's possible I don't think four but
that's why I said if we're gonna really
go down this road here that the jet that
the the Browns should have popped up
from four
told the Giants we know you don't want
to take anybody other than sake one yeah
we're taking him right all right and you
want to go out of two and you don't want
to go so far right and the Jets aren't
gonna be the ones going anywhere from
three take off you want to make it get
our core get a quarterback here's the
four it'll be better than any deal that
you get from somebody else highest pick
you because you're gonna go to four for
another and then go one two rip the knob
off whoever the hell you want get them
both yeah sack one and get Mayfield if
that's who you want right and get them
both I think I may you know they stayed
one four and then they took Denzel Ward
who got hurt right so that to me
could've taken Denzel Washington they're
still Denzel Washington it has he ever
been on the show you gotta get has been
on the show on the phone here I was I
was in a store I had to go to the bat I
was on the phone with a friend from
Michigan I had to pee go into this store
come out of the into the into the shop
no one's there but the shopkeeper and
Denzel Washington which is like the
greatest moment and like tons of teams
like like you know pop online start
talking time wearing I'm wearing a Wiest
mode shirt Dianne Wiest face we smoked
in a scene right so I'm sinner and he
likes my shirt we start talking and I am
talking I mean he knew our show cheap
seats a little bit but he couldn't
remember our name my name and he goes
what's you and your brother's name and I
was like where the Sklar brothers and he
just looks at me and he's like the scala
brothers this kelabra talk about like a
magnetic dude who you just get it in
like one second you're like I understand
everything completely
he's like a gigantic superstar and you
just get it like so the Browns should
take it him and set a dense award well
certainly if Denzel Ward isn't gonna be
playing anytime soon I mean it was an
odd choice didn't you think yeah I'm up
in the draft and you're saying yourself
what what they are I said it before I
will say it again they're wearing is
amazing waste mode we wait smush mode we
submit full-on waste mode yeah I mean
she said it before you said it they've
got they've got playmakers all over the
spot all over the lotto
the field they're great I agree in terms
of talent let's have some of the most
talented players in the NFL on the same
roster and it's possible they have Dez
Bryant Mouse by the end without a
contract I don't know I don't know what
was that I mean yeah I mean he's it he's
a decent third option are you watching
hard knocks yeah a little Saint Bob
Wiley that guy who looks like Wilford
Brimley had a lovechild with wood Duff
I've always said this about I've always
said I've always said this Wilford
Brimley Michael Craig Stadler Mike
Holmgren and Andy Reid never seen the
four of those guys in a room together
same dude same guy they won't get old
and they won't ever die that's right
yeah Caroline Andy Rolf course no I got
that you know good to see you guys get
to check out these guys in Ann Arbor if
you're in the Michigan area and check
out CNN's history of comedy series part
two part of season two pardon me a
history of comedy series on CNN roast
battle comedy central view from the
cheap seats podcast dumb people town
true crime podcast oh my gosh you guys
are all good in the hood
and I'll be on your pod next week next
week the I is an episode drop that drops
if you will all right thanks for coming
on here guys for having these guys the
Sklar brothers here on the Rich Eisen
show we'll let you know how we're
rolling next week and how we're wrapping
up this show in a moment the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience